this is the X8 Pro robovac from our
sponsor yui clean and it's just about
the most compact Auto emptying Robot
vacuum I've ever seen with the main goal
of taking care of your floors and
carpets for you for up to 45 days with
basically no input from you at all which
is so important for those in the Tech
Community like myself who would much
rather spend their time with tech or of
course with your friends and family now
if you're wondering how it's able to
automate everything for $45 stay
straight well it's due to the
combination of the XA Pro large capacity
2.5 L bacteria static dust bag which
safely stores dust and debris for up to
45 days being super easy to replace and
the second part of the equation is the
XA Pros patented pet hair active
anti-tangle brush design which makes
89.3% of pet hair get sucked up into the
dust bin instead of getting stuck which
means far less maintenance from you
compared to other robovac and yes it
still does include a little tool to cut
long hairs off the brush roll further
down the road and I placed it
conveniently into the self-empty station
for safekeeping now as far as cleaning
the carpets this thing does an excellent
job because of yui clean's deeper
cleaning V5 with their twin turbine
suction system with 2 times
4,000 of strong suction power giving you
1.8 times the cleaning performance on
the carpet leaving nothing in between
now there were two other things that
really impressed me about the X8 Pro
including the reliable app and the
cleaning performance for the floors but
first I've got to show you how easy it
was to unbox and set up everything was
laid out very nicely and most of the
components were set up right out of the
gate including the pre-bagged dust bin
that was so Compact and light I could
lift it with one hand and I love love
how the power plug has a little slot so
it looks clean on the back and doesn't
interfere the vacuum itself comes
jam-packed with a bunch of sensors
including the AI mapping sensors on the
front and a bumper design for if it
bumps into things like small table legs
the wheels adjust up and down to
increase cleaning performance on rugs
and it comes with a pretty large Dustbin
on the inside with a filter which of
course vacuums up into the base station
automatically it even comes comes with a
mopping feature with an included mop pad
that's attached using Velcro so you can
wash it later and that attachment snaps
on very easily onto the vacuum and can
be removed by holding down this button
on both sides the included water tank is
very easy to remove and refill which
will keep the pad saturated with water
for mopping the floors and the entire
base station sits on this plastic floor
cover to avoid leaving any long-term
water or moisture residue on your floors
now getting into the setup it was super
easy to just download the yui clean app
choose the X8 Pro and connect it to
Wi-Fi within minutes with a little popup
that had me update the firmware within
moments and get it ready to go to get
started the first thing you'll have to
do is tap the quick mapping button which
will have the robovac drive around
scanning your entire floor giving you
this super detailed map on the main
screen of the app so all you have to do
is tap the play button and it'll get
right to cleaning the vacuuming
performance was very impressive picking
up huge unrealistic piles of crushed
tortilla chips that I left and that was
actually before I went into the settings
and set the suction power to the max it
did a really good job hugging the
corners while navigating around them
with a nice back and forth path to make
sure nothing is missed and even if the
brush does sometimes knock a little bit
of crumbs around it comes back around
again and sucks them right up and while
that vacuuming it's also mopping behind
it with the mop pad that's automatically
saturated with water and to my surprise
it actually works quite well and you can
see the Reflections in the light
wherever it mops around now it's
recommended to take the mop pads off if
you want to clean your carpets which is
super easy and simple to do but they
also have the nogo or no mop Zone
features so I set one up for my living
room rug so it's going to avoid it when
the mop pad is installed I also tried
out the Zone cleaning feature which is
great for spot cleaning under the dining
table after dinner if that's all that
you want it to clean and it did an
excellent job navigating around and
under all of the chairs and best of all
it's got a ton of extra settings to
customize including scheduling your
cleanings on a daily basis or whatever
else and with the default settings it'll
come back and vacuum up all of the dust
out of the robo ax dust bin straight up
into the 2.5 L dust bag so you could
just leave it to do its thing for a
month and a half before easily replacing
the bag so with that said I'm very
impressed by the cleaning performance
especially for carpets with its two
times 4,000 pas of suction power and pet
hair Active anti-tangle technology so if
you're interested in checking one of
these out you can use the link in the
description below to buy one today
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next
[Music]
video